it's so it's just so rad the [ __ ] the
like the legacy man yeah like
did you see how in um like that
knoxville had his article on gq magazine
and they just you know talk to me for uh
like you know quotes or whatever and i
said dude like
when i found out knoxville wanted to do
a fourth jackass movie after a 10-year
hiatus
i was like
no dude like we [ __ ] like i mean not
no but my concern was that we had gotten
away with so much and we had we had this
this fantastic legacy and then now all
it would take would just be one [ __ ]
stupid accident one [ __ ] stupid thing
and and like it would all be out the
window you know like being like oh i
love these guys where we're just [ __ ]
[ __ ] and now knoxville's in a
wheelchair [ __ ] some just weird thing
to just ruin everything and uh it
reminds me of when i asked you what
would happen if the shark bit me when i
had the fish hooked through my face i'm
like dude we were hours away from the
shore of hurricane devastated louisiana
like what would happen if the shark bit
me and you said i don't know man we got
god
and like and then once again dude we
made a fourth jackass movie and like
like so much to lose you know i'm like
dude we've survived so much we've
like gotten away with so much we've got
this beautiful legacy yeah we're gonna
put it all on the line and like you you
weren't as distracted as i was like said
knoxville i went to lunch with him uh
this is before you found out and uh
and he's like hey man i
think i want to
and that's the first time he's ever been
the one that like it's usually me that
goes to him and says hey i think right
you know you're you're showing up on
wild boys right one on wild boys
you showed up ready to die on wild boys
why don't we make another movie tonight
like if you're gonna take a bullet like
let's do it on a movie screen not on the
tv that was how jack got let's let's
tell that story the last trip we ever
went on for wild boys i think it was
understood that it would be the last
trip or not no well no
no okay but it ended up being the last
trip doesn't russia yeah our last trip
was to russia and oh boy was there a
[ __ ] was that a wild trip we brought
knoxville yeah we brought nonchalant it
was a wild trip so we had this one day
of filming with like
what was it like what do you mean it was
a wild trip
like the russian secret service where we
went to a terrorist group we went to
some yeah special ops who knows what the
assassins basically and they had a nine
millimeter gun with rubber bullets in it
yeah they had a [ __ ] attack dog they
had this [ __ ] and not so says
shoot me with the [ __ ] nine
millimeter rubber bullet while the dog
attacks me
well they they wanted to scare us
you know they didn't get it like they
thought that like they set up like a
little obstacle course where you were
supposed to run around and run by the
scary dog as it's like it's some big ass
mastiff type weird yeah i've never seen
that dog before like a giant
dangerous dog that's on a chain and
knocks like well i want to get bit by
that i'm like
that just like don't just let the dog
bite the dog to bite me but shoot me
while i and they wanted to have a
shootout with rubber bullets but they
weren't trying they weren't they didn't
think they were going to [ __ ] shoot
and i'm like
and then like let's definitely get there
and nachos just ready to die like
[ __ ]
get stopped by the [ __ ] at the same
time i remember yeah and we've had some
issues with the rubber bullets like yeah
that's not neces they call it less
lethal
i've never been around those rubber
bullets but they were shot out of a nine
mil so we did you know he's like shoot
me i'm like well let's do some testing
like we did with this like back in the
day somebody less lethal i haven't
removed the word lethal
do you know you know the story about the
first time we ever shot like
the bean bag i wasn't there you weren't
there like we it didn't air because i
made the guy test like we found some
stunt guy that was willing to do it
and so he ended in there
like this was not on the first movie
this is before the this is from
tv show all right knoxville goes online
and buys these little [ __ ] beanbag
bullets
so that we we if you don't mind just
it's non-sequitur out of yeah
uh
he went online
and found
um
yeah beanbag beanbag boat so he buys a
shotgun he buys three shells uh-huh like
that have the bean bag packed in the
show like and we're trusting that this
is like
yeah cool we just found a stuntman
that's willing to use the shotgun and
shoot him
with it
and so we're gonna shoot this for a tv
show cool um
and then we get there and i start to
like this is me for the first time
probably using good judgment i'm like
all right well wait a minute
we don't know what these things do
right like i'm just trusting that this
is a shotgun shell and it's going to
shoot a [ __ ] right bean bag so i'm
like all right
tell you what let's we we've got a
watermelon we set a watermelon up yeah
shoot the watermelon
[ __ ] blows right through the
watermelon right through the plywood
behind it
like
wow
holy [ __ ] like that through you know
three quarter inch plywood hole right
through it like that beanbag did
like hold on so then
put two more sheets of plywood
shoot drew target on the plywood shoot
that
first of all
it doesn't hit the target it goes near
the target
but blows right through three sheets of
plywood this little [ __ ] bean bag i'm
like you can't i'm not gonna yeah we
have one more shell thank god we had the
two shells were practiced now we're down
to the one and knox like well we're here
let's just do it
i'm like are you [ __ ] kidding like
did you did we see the same thing i
filmed it
you know there's a hole in three sheets
of plywood and a watermelon that doesn't
didn't even blow the watermelon up it
just went right through the watermelon
and right through the plywood there's
like a little hole like a [ __ ] gun
bullet not a you know how you expect it
to blow it yeah like the worst kind like
because these things fly like little
frisbees this is the early days
right you know bean bags like if you
shot something with it it's gonna go
right in him so what made it okay when
it was time to do the moves you didn't
do it that day we didn't do it that day
we found a more legit company
that shot a bigger projectile that had a
tail the tail made it a little more
accurate still not accurate like it's
crazy that they [ __ ] shoot these
things at people like it's crazy because
they don't go where they're supposed to
i don't know if they've gotten better
since but when we did jackass one right
we were able to do it
and uh but we had a professional
it had to go through a lot of safety
measures and we did we had plenty of
them to do the testing and all that so
but i called it off and knoxville was
still willing the only he was mad at me
when we walked away without the footage
like he's so gnarly [ __ ] like why are
you willing to do that like that's not
we don't need the footage that bad like
this is fantastic so gnarly and then
when we're in rush the same thing like
just well we're here let's get the
footage i'm like can we just run around
and get scared by this [ __ ] and not get
that footage today because i i don't i
think this is gnarlier than right and
it's mtv2 right
and so like right when we got home i'm
like [ __ ] if you still have this
in like you clearly
want to go
do this [ __ ] but you came out for
nothing to shoot with us and right
russia let's do another one and he was
like yeah i'm ready and so that was
jackass 2. i don't remember exactly what
happened on jackass 3 but it was the
same amount of time it passed it feels
like the right amount of jackass 3 was
that a lot of us had
traded in certain vices
and uh
and and replaced them with with
healthier things knoxville's
just
became addicted to
nut shots
that was during jackass three right
right right that's when we're shooting
oh like you're saying no no where i was
born out of like
what motivated i guess it was it was all
you i think because i yeah we just we've
done the 24 hour takeover you just come
out of surprise like this
i was getting shot with [ __ ] oranges
out of some [ __ ] crazy high power
cannon with matt hoffman in spain
and he said
uh tremaine's trying to do a third
jackass movie i was like really he says
that's what he says you know so i think
that was all you yeah um and dude but
then he pulls me aside and says i'm
ready dude i'm like are you kidding and
then he pulls out a notebook with like
full of [ __ ] that he'd been just
gathering for the last 10 years
he's just such a different breed of dude
i guess we all are
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]